from PIX11 once again New York PD NYPD
cops ordered to patrol in uniform
prepare for mobilization after Trump
indictment so this was just the end of
the last week as it was being announced
Trump was going to head to New York but
this has been a consistent story since
the announcement of the looming
indictment before it was confirmed New
York police fully mobilized every every
officer told to be in uniform and get
ready my question is for what you know
what's interesting is we had our Trump
supporters going to go around or what we
had a reporter out there last week who
went out to the courthouse the night of
the uh like with the with the indictment
I think it was um
Wednesday she went out on or maybe it
was Thursday I don't know anything
anyway uh she went out and she was
talking to some of the cops who were
stationed outside the courthouse and
they had all said they were talking to
her about it and they said that they
were told that this wasn't going to
happen
for like another month and then all of a
sudden they were all called up they all
were told that they had to pull doubles
and they had to get out there right away
and they were all kind of pissed they
were like we didn't think this was
happening now that's also a way to
agitate people and that you're just
agitating the cops and their families
that is agitating so the way it must be
looked at it's an indictment trying to
lead to incitement
this is a direct incitement campaign
where they're trying to raise the
temperature in the room to try to spark
a backlash that they want to be violent
who is they the National Security State
that deep State the regime media because
right-wing violence makes the regime
more powerful I'm at the point where I
just don't see how it how it matters no
one on the right like the bifurcation of
culture in this country is is complete
none of us here are swayed by any
arguments about right-wing violence we
know what antifa does we know that I've
experienced it absolutely and For
Heaven's Sake conservatives don't even
want to go around waving flags around
peacefully they barely want to go
outside and protest at all if anything
some do but mostly they don't that's
right but the narrative among the left
is they truly believe it so I was uh I
was at a a casino called Maryland Live
this past weekend and I was playing
poker with the boys as I often do and
talk about and the guy to my left said
that all of the people on January 6
should be executed oh my goodness no
kidding like he got so someone brought
up politics this is a regular guy he
doesn't know much about politics he's uh
executed executed not kidding he's he's
uh these are like grandmas being like oh
look at the pictures well there were
violent guys out there a lot there would
be a lot of dead federal agents sure but
listen so there was violence there's a
riot there's people fighting with cops
I've seen worse at antifa protests but I
get into the capital on one side of the
building the doors are open but the cops
people are let in and I'm talking to
this guy because someone brought up the
economy which led to someone bringing up
Joe Biden and you're not supposed to
talk politics at these tables because of
what happens and then I asked the guy
what he thought and he was a really
funny guy he was really cool we were
getting along having a great time just
having fun some jokes were made some fun
poker hands and then when he got into he
got really angry and it was just like
those people what I saw with my own eyes
in January 6 they should all be executed
every single one of them that's treason
against this country and I saw what
happened and I said I was I well you
hear about happened on 5 29 and he says
no what's that I was like when the when
the leftists the far left they they tore
the barricades out of the White House
that fired to St John's Church fire
bombed the guard post and then the the
Trump was forced into an emergency
bunker and he goes I I don't know what
you're I don't know anything about that
and I'm like that's it right there
this guy was not political he said he
hated all politicians but the messaging
that reaches him is
insurrectionists or traitors and I have
no idea what antifa is yeah
and imagine a new wave of riots called
the Trump riots
that's what they want to see bubble up
but I don't I just I just I just can't
see it I can't well you were the one Tim
that you think the country would
collapse if they remanded him but not
because people on the right are going to
romp around with guns that's probably
unlikely yeah they're unlikely the
reason I believe that if Donald Trump
did not surrender okay the country would
collapse is because
a country only exists based on
confidence it is an abstract idea that
tethers people together you look at
other countries where they do not have
confidence in the government you end up
with Civil War you end up with
corruption with bribery Etc and then
very little in power of the government
other than guns
if Donald Trump stayed in Florida and
announced to the nation I do not find
these charges to be legitimate these are
political it's a political persecution
and a Witch Hunt so I'm going to
completely ignore it
what precedent would be set nationally
that New York was powerless to stop
someone who committed what they say our
felonies and Florida refuses to
extradite yes so that's that's two
questions so it's speculation because
it's not happening but it's interesting
first the precedent would be you file an
extradition order the second is Florida
has to choose whether or not to honor it
and they probably would do you think
that you think Ron DeSantis that's the
question I don't think the governor has
all that Authority I don't know how all
the particulars work I think that he
wasn't going to get involved yeah
not getting involved and dishonoring a
Interstate extradition order are two
different things
can you imagine this is all speculation
but I think it's helpful but but let's
just entertain these two potential
outcomes the extradition order denied
Rhonda Santa sang We're not involved
which I think would be a pretty ballsy
and cool thing to do but that's
absolutely I completely agree yeah but
but what does that mean for law
enforcement as a country the other
scenario I mentioned sure on imagine Ron
DeSantis saying we have no choice I am
hereby ordering State Police to
Mar-A-Lago to arrest and transport Trump
against his will to New York that would
be insane exactly but that's what would
have to happen hold on we have we have a
precedent of
a couple things so the idea of a state
or a locality
saying that other people's laws don't
apply to us is not new yeah California's
doing California is doing it with the
gender stuff Vermont I'm just trying to
do it Los Angeles San Francisco Portland
Seattle Chicago Boston Philadelphia are
all Sanctuary cities where they defy
federal law and don't work federal
agents so that's not a perfect example
but this idea of blue States and blue
cities carving out their kind of own
place to you know play if you will so
that's one argument the second thing is
what would happen in a standoff between
a former president and Florida State
Troopers it'd be impossible to know
goodness the question the question would
be what would be Trump's end goal which
is why Trump is going to New York
because Trump the reason why Trump is in
New York is he sees massive upside to
this because Alvin Bragg is doing what
the other DA's decided not to do he's
raising money he's getting points in the
polls and Donald Trump is now seeing
himself is now being positioned as the
Martyr of the American right yep that is
that is so wild and being the Martyr is
incredibly popular and martyrdom is a
way to win popularity and what do you
think the American left is thinking
about it
depends who's who you're talking to Mark
Elias or your average crazy person in
Brooklyn they're cheering for it well
yeah Mark Elias is probably not cheering
for it that's a separate issue he's much
more strategic that's the question about
the national Democratic party is
interesting yes the average Trump
derangement syndrome Democrat is saying
finally Joy Bahar on the viewers fell
into it but these people are savages and
they they they they're never going to
stop in their bloodthirsty quest for
revenge and that's my point
we have two completely bifurcated
worldviews and cultures one that is
calling for Injustice and one that is
saying it's good that Trump turned
himself into Injustice it makes no sense
well no no I'm not saying yeah I I I see
it both ways so Define the Injustice you
have to you have to have the ends in
Minds right your final and formal causes
developed and I don't think that would
have been necessarily prudent for Trump
to say you got to go send the Troopers
after me it would have felt very like
George Wallace you know 1960s or 70s now
having Florida stand up and have the
entire Florida State Troopers Stand Down
against an extradition order that would
have been interesting but what I think
does need to happen and the only mature
response that I've called for for quite
some time is Republican DA's and
Republican AGS need to start indicting
and investigating members of the
Democrat crime family one that we can
all agree on is fraudulent is the BLM
criminal Enterprise that materially
benefited with a hundred million dollars
and the Sun summer 2020 and they've been
untouched wasn't act blue being used to
facilitate donations to some of these
organizations correct yeah and act blue
is a harder case to make but we can say
just with black lives matter Global
Network with Patrice cullers we now know
there was material charitable fraud
under any sort of reading she was buying
all those houses yeah six million dollar
mansion in Malibu for a content creator
and the money went missing I guess the
money went missing all these sources oh
yeah you could just just to make track
check me on all of it right there was a
bunch of that she has a multiple
multiple real estate Empire right she
also paid her was boyfriend now husband
for security services for a healthy sum
you could fact check me
um on that it was quite a lot yeah NBC
News is not what I would use as yours no
but you know that's why it's just gonna
take you more time to find the numbers
BLM leaders condemn allegations of
mismanaged funds okay it's a word salad
headline they're condemning their own
mission but it was even reported in it
here's L.A times black lives matter
leader accused of stealing 10 million
dollars there we go sure that that right
there so let's just pause there and
that's actually a separate one that's
not BLM Global Network right but my
guess is that somebody in a red State
don't what's his name again this is is
that the global Network Foundation
Bowers sure
um why is there not widespread
investigations and indictments into the
BLM charitable fraud now that matters
because if we if we want to have the
promise of equal justice and the 14th
Amendment it's like okay you go after
Donald Trump who has become a martyr of
the conservative right there you go
Washington examiner is a great site so
that's BLM Millions unaccounted for
after leaders quietly jump so I'm I
deal in the 501c3 world every dollar is
audited every dollar we have an audit
committee we have a CFO I can't even
sign checks it takes two people in the
organization right we do 990s we deal
with the IRS very very high standard of
financial accountability at Turning
Point USA this year is outright
charitable fraud now why does this
matter because the counter argument said
well Charlie that's just some charity no
no no
BLM was the kind of vehicle of choice
for the activists left so you go get
Donald Trump in New York then fine we're
going to go take BLM and put them on
trial and go through the charitable
fraud of how they raise 100 million
dollars and got 83 billion dollars in
pledges from Corporate America and where
did the money go that would be that's so
much that would be a prudent Act of
deterrence that would actually I think
open up
the legal conversation and that's just
one example of a hundred that I a few
years ago
there were people telling me that what's
happening today would never happen
because the government would not allow
it that the government was Secure that
the the Deep State apparatus the
whatever you want to call it does not
allow these kinds of things because it's
destabilized that sort of things like
Trump being arrested like BLM Summer of
Love who says that like this was in 2018
were you reading like keyboards or
something no like wait what the these
are these are mainstream conservatives I
I've never heard that but sure you've
never heard people say that the country
can't collapse that no I'm saying that
Trump can't be indicted like I don't I
haven't heard that yeah so so in 2018
the idea that Donald Trump would
actually be impeached they were like
they won't allow something like that
okay well impeachment is different than
indictment but sure continue yeah well
but indictment was even on the table
there wasn't even a criminal charges
that were okay I think I misunderstood
what you were saying in 2018 when I was
talking about how we are heading towards
a collapse or Civil War and again I
stress I didn't make the idea a
Princeton Professor was talking about
the cult of wore numerous Outlets were
talking I see what you're saying people
were saying that can never happen the
government is an entity in and of itself
the Deep state it will not lose control
in that matter it doesn't care about the
left doesn't care about the right order
and now what are we seeing as the years
go on the federal government is being
bifurcated into mostly an establishment
left and more new there's no right
there's no opposition there's no
opposition there is just the hyper
partisan hyperpolarization of federal
government and so what we end up seeing
today is Donald Trump just flew to New
York to surrender on bogus criminal
charges there will be no opposition to
that
this will get worse as the years go on
there is no reason to believe that these
people in power are going to decide to
pull things back so they don't have to
why why would they what is the mechanism
by which they will say hey let's let's
slow down here so the only way they stop
is if we stop them and so I agree if the
current trajectory continues everything
you just said will happen I'm a big
believer in Free Will and agency and the
ability to do something so I'm going to
use my platform to call on what the only
thing I think that could stop it which
is deterrence which is to get DA's and
AGS to indict Democrat crime member
families if we don't do that everything
you're saying is true but so my my issue
there is this country is so bifurcated
what you're describing would just be the
exact same thing to them as it is of
course it is it's equal and opposite
reaction you punch us we punch you and
then it escalates to further so the
question is stabilization what
escalation is better than being pummeled
well I I
depends on how I calculating it to end
this and the problem like I'm trying to
quell the violence my heart is trying to
calm down the temperature my heart is
saying we're not going to stop until you
stop and and the issue is true if you
have a friend that smacks you a lot and
you're like if you did that again I'm
going to smack you back but they do it
again and you smack it back they stop
that's deterring but this is not no I
completely it's fair warning you're like
what you're doing is wrong there's no
friends I completely disagree there's
there's numerous examples about history
where the the pushback just led to a
escalation until war broke out and
people all killed each other we had a
civil war in this country they didn't
just say whoa this Vine is growing too
much guys that's the greatest stuff
that's a good thing
argument is good and Sherman decided to
March to the Sea rather savagely and and
Savage is an understatement yeah it is
he said I got an idea I'm so sick of
these people I'm going to burn their
cities to the ground kill children and
Destroy Farmland all the way down so
they starve and die
of scorched Earth Warfare so the no no
no it was first time the United States
it was when I believe they coined
scorched Earth so let me just frame it
though because I hate to reduce things
to binaries but the American right has a
choice
option one keep doing what we are doing
which is to send strongly worded press
releases and op-eds and hope things get
better
Choice two indict indict use political
power and hope it gets better they're
both bad options I agree I like them the
the Forgiveness Arc for Donald like if
you're really pummeled and beaten down
by Society so hard and you still stand
up and forgive people for it that's a
message that will resonate for thousands
of years I think that's powerful not
gonna happen it could I think I think
they're lying in the polls too they're
they're trying to make the argument that
they want Trump to be the nominee so
they can beat him in 2024. but they
didn't beat him last time well I mean
they did beat him once they beat him
last time but they don't but they don't
have anything right now there's no one
Biden can't do it Biden didn't campaign
he hid in his basement there was a
lockdown where melon bouts were sent to
everyone's home I totally agree with you
they don't have any of these tools so
unless H1 a h5n1 hits yeah and then they
do another lockdown like a spine flu 2.0
or something Biden is done do you
remember people in their cars right
right yes
front of the stage yes Biden is a proven
failure the country is in shambles that
guy I mentioned who talked about
executing j6ers also said it's Biden's
fault the economy is bad so my point is
just they can't try this game twice and
I do believe they're going to try
they're putting out polls where it's
like if an election was held today Biden
would win DeSantis would beat Trump but
Biden uh they're saying that DeSantis
would beat Biden but and Trump would
lose to Biden and they're trying to make
the case that we should support DeSantis
for the primary I think they are lying
once again in the polls so can I
validate what you're saying yeah can you
go to a website it's number
270to win.com
yeah this every 10 years we do a census
as mandated by the Constitution most
people don't know this but the map has
slightly changed in Trump and the
Republican favor for the first time for
2024. so the maps are good for three
cycles and then you read do them good
for three Cycles actually two cycles
redo them well what do you mean it's
right right here it's saying let me show
you okay so let's make let's let's
assume Texas goes red is that fair
enough to say oh easily and Florida yep
okay let's assume Pennsylvania goes blue
please and then New Hampshire goes blue
and then all of Maine goes blue really
yeah let me show you Michigan goes blue
I know what I'm doing here so and
Minnesota goes blue and Minnesota goes
and then Nevada goes blue and Nevada
goes below Iowa goes red Iowa and Ohio
goes rent and Ohio and North Carolina
goes red and that's okay so what you
have right here is why they fear Trump
all Trump has to do is win Arizona
Georgia and Wisconsin and he's the
president of the United States three
states he won in 2016. three states that
received Zuckerberg money three states
that have elected Statewide Republicans
and three states that have more Republic
well two states that have more
Republicans registered than Democrats in
Georgia and Arizona and one state that's
50 50. this is why the Democrats are
indicting Trump the map has changed
if this was not the map in 20s what I'm
telling you are we going to say uh so
Nebraska had that one District I turned
it red well no if you even if you don't
it goes 271 right if it's 271 without it
with it it's 272. yeah and so you 270 to
win is all you need so the Democrats
know this so therefore
Donald Trump can't not only can he win
the presidency this map heavily favors
the Republican to win the presidency
this is interesting even even the the so
the only real consideration I think I
don't even know if Arizona is
necessarily I'm I'm not as worried about
Arizona I live in Arizona right it's
it's it's a challenge you think so okay
it's a 50 50 state Cinema is going to be
a formidable Senate candidate if she
runs as an independent
that's good for Republicans it's good I
think Arizona with the proper get out
the vote ballot chasing operation which
we can talk about
is going to be fine My Philosophy my
hypothesis is the entire United States
election comes down to three states
comes down to Seven Counties and this is
why they fear Trump so much this is not
a national election mind you
Pennsylvania is blue yeah you're right
you're right in 2016 Trump won with I
think 88 000 votes across the three
states he needed he needed a Michigan or
a Pennsylvania in addition to a
Wisconsin because the census map favored
the Democrats because of the Sun Belt
surge it's because Florida has gained
population so significantly it's a red
State because Texas has a New York and
California and Illinois have lost
population the stars have aligned where
the Republican is now in a much easier
spot to win the White House than ever
before you better believe Mark Elias
knows this that's why Elias and the
national Democrats are not thrilled
about this indictment they're just
saying what are you doing to win those
three states what do you want to do this
when to win those three states and this
is helping them there oh yeah his polls
have gone up oh not only that upper
middle class white Suburban voters are
not thrilled about the idea of over
prosecution because they kind of get
that what that means that's a that
resonates that's that's a democrat-based
thing let me tell you the funny thing is
this guy I'm talking to who's had
execute the j6s which is insane to me
also said this country over prosecutes
well so there you go and it's it was
this is an interesting thing it sounds
like a walking contradiction AKA a swing
voter absolutely he was a PA swing voter
well that and so you look at it because
people say how do we win Michigan how to
win Nevada how to win Pennsylvania you
don't need to and so you look at the map
you then you then Focus very precisely
there's not just a path there is a great
probability Trump becomes president
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time